[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi 4
novembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité départementale
de la semaine voici les titres une
centaine de migrants sont arrivés à
maurepas ce matin suite au démantèlement
d'un campement parisien c'est la
deuxième fois que la ville accueille des
migrants une nouvelle qui ne passe pas
auprès du maire les républicains de la
commune vous l'entendrez et pour
approfondir cette actualité guy poupart
est notre invité fil rouge le maire sans
étiquette de bonnel qui est la première
ville de france à avoir accueilli des
migrants c'était en septembre 2015 dans
le reste de l'actualité nous reviendrons
sur un projet de logement étudiant xxl
actuellement en cours de construction
sur le campus de paris saclay ou un film
bientôt à la fiche produit par un ace
saint quentinois ils sont donc une
centaine une centaine de migrants hommes
femmes et enfants à être arrivé ce matin
par bus à maurepas pour s'installer dans
la salle des fêtes de la ville une
arrivée qui fait suite au démantèlement
du campement parisien situé à stalingrad
qui est qui déplaît au maire de la ville
qui était présent sur place la précision
de michael et demi d'euros patrick
jacques de dixmude et mélanie poquet
morpain fait une nouvelle fois face à
l'arrivée de migrants dans sa commune
après avoir reçu une centaine de
personnes en juillet dernier au gymnase
des baissière la ville est obligé
d'accueillir à partir de ce vendredi 4
novembre 99 migrants principalement
venus d'iran et d'afghanistan
cette décision imposée par l'état fait
suite au démantèlement du camp de la
villette à paris il s'agissait
d'accueillir pour des raisons de
fraternité républicaine déjà en
souffrance
qui logeaient dans des conditions
inadmissibles dans un premier temps la
mairie de maurepas décidé de s'opposer
c'est arrivé en manifestant devant le
gymnase des vestiaires je suis très en
colère parce que maurepas a déjà rempli
son devoir d'humanité pour accueillir
des débits grand l'été dernier au
gymnase des baissière et une seconde
fois l'état réquisitionne ce bâtiment en
pleine année scolaire je ne comprends
pas je ne comprends pas pourquoi sur les
262 communes des yvelines en tout cas
sur le permet de 50 ans d'une ville
c'est encore maurepas qui a été un choix
après une heure de négociations un
compromis a été trouvé entre la
préfecture et la ville pour installer
les migrants dans la salle des fêtes
c'est une une alternative donc j'ai fait
un pas vers l'état
pour éviter justement de pénaliser les
mort nazis avec la suppression pure et
simple de 15 jours d'activités sportives
dans un gymnase qui est extrêmement
utilisez donc l'état accepté cette
solution et je m'en réjouis
malgré tout maintenant je me pose des
questions quand même pour l'avenir pour
éviter que ça se reproduise a balancé tu
dois déçus puisque l'hébergement
d'urgence de gens en difficulté va être
assurée c'est un objectif et avec
l'accord du maire les migrants devraient
rester jusqu'au 18 novembre dans la
salle des fêtes de bord passe selon les
dernières informations communiquées par
la préfecture
ils pourraient être jusqu'à 350 dans les
ibid
et pour parler justement de cette
actualité et guy poupart est notre
invité ce soir bonsoir avec guy poupart
vous êtes le maire sans étiquette de
bonnel une petite commune yvelinoise à
la frontière de l'essonne et votre
particularité à vous c'est d'être la
première ville de france à avoir
accueilli des migrants dès la rentrée
2015 au plus fort de la crise et
migratoire européenne il y a donc plus
d'un an est ce que vous comprenez la
réaction de la mairie de maurepas et de
la plupart du temps des maires des
communes qui reçoivent des migrants qui
ont l'impression qu'on leur impose un
peu ça qu'il n'y a pas de concertation
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
alors le point de vue du maire de
maurepas oui je le partage puisque c'est
vrai qu'il est toujours choquant de voir
tout court on se voit obligé de
donner un gymnase à des admis grand
puisque très sincèrement j'ai toujours
dit que il fallait quand même une
organisation - minimum c'est à dire
qu'il faut au moins un lieu d'accueil
prévu adéquat qui est fait pour c'est
absolument incontournable sinon on se
risque à avoir une
un
refoulement de la parole - de la
population qui ne va pas comprendre déjà
la population peut parfois être pas
forcément d'accord avec de tels de telle
arrivée et le fait de faire ça derrière
leur dos rond sans forcément les
prévenir ça peut amplifier ce sentiment
là c'est une opération qui est difficile
enfin les filières d'émigration une
commune et jeudi à plus forte raison si
ces migrants arrivent dans un bâtiment
qui était prévu pour d'autres activités
ceux qui justement n'était pas le cas
sur le net c'était un monastère qui
n'était plus occupé donc c'était que
nous nous avons nous avoir échappé à ce
genre de cette situation et met tout à
fait sûre s'il la préfecture nous dit à
nous également d'accueillir des migrants
dans notre jumelage je pense que j'aurai
la même réaction que le maire de
montfort en parlant des réactions en
septembre en septembre 2015 quelle était
la vôtre même si c'était pas sur un
équipement municipal mais tout de suite
ça a été pris du bon côté abonnés loup
alors il ya eu des inquiétudes
initialement inquiétudes inquiétudes
partagées entre les habitants et les
élus mais les élus ont dit il faut que
nous fassions quelque chose pour voir
pour pour justement calmer l'inquiétude
nouveaux habitants donc nous avons
découvert le 9 septembre 2015 l'arrivée
de 78 migrants nous avions été prévenus
quelques pas même pas jours quelques
heures avant de cette arrivée et nous
avons pris le parti de tout faire pour
que ça se passe le mieux qu'ils soient
entre les habitants et le site du
monastère des oranges et donc notre nous
avons tenté de lever cette inquiétude au
niveau des habitants quels étaient ses
inquiétudes justement qu'ils ont pu vous
exprimer à vous directement alors là
l'inquiétude des coulées de d'image de
migrants que nous avions en boucle les
jours précédents et notamment je me
rappelle encore c'est bien gravé dans ma
mémoire des affrontements entre les
migrants qui franchissaient la frontière
hongroise et qui se tabassent est en
fait avec
les militaires en croit tout ça me
disais mais je dis mais c'est pas
possible c'est gens là vont arriver chez
nous je me suis mais
c'était incompréhensible et finalement
il ya un décalage entre la réalité est
ce qu'on peut voir dans les news et noir
médias énorme énorme énorme énorme quand
nous avons arriver vu arriver le 9
septembre un bus avec 78 personnes ce
sont 78 jeunes avec quelques femmes il y
avait quatre femmes trois enfants tous
je dirais en les voyant un pied
tous disant bonjour merci quasiment un
arrivants ayant plutôt l'attitude de
jean défrayer inquiet a battu par nous
n'avions plus du tout envie de leur dire
non on ne veut pas de jour on s'est dit
il faut absolument qu'on leur tende la
main quand les accompagnent mais c'est
il a fallu vraiment qu'on les voie pour
que cette attitude soit soit elle que je
vous la décrivez selon la préfecture des
yvelines 350 personnes en tout en plus
doivent être hébergés sur le département
des yvelines donc 250 en plus décent qui
sont installés à mort pense moment est
ce que vous vous avez été approché de
nouveau pour accueillir des migrants
lorsque vous avez de la place encore
abonné non alors en fait il faut savoir
que les 78 qui sont arrivés en septembre
2015 ne n'y sont plus ils sont repartis
au fil des
régularisations des des papiers et donc
ils ont été remplacés par d'autres
personnes venant d'ailleurs d'autres
pays puisque au début c'était
exclusivement certains irakiens depuis
nous avons deux un peu tout à fait tous
les pays que l'on cite aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont qui sont chez nous
et
du coup en fait aujourd'hui on est plus
78 1991 et en fait c'est la capacité
d'accueil maximum qui est autorisé
aujourd'hui pour le monastère des autres
donc je ne pense qu'il n'y a pas de
raison pour que cela n'arrive 30 45 ans
va franchement par contre 6 entendrait
le maire de ponelle hurler parce que il
faut aussi rester recevoir les gens de
manière décente les pas question que on
entre on entasse des gens dans un
monastère sous prétexte qu'il faut les
accueillir en tout cas bonne elle depuis
septembre 2015 est cité dans la presse
pour pour montrer on va dire un exemple
un peu inverse de ce qui peut être
montrée parfois dans les médias comme
quoi ça se passe très bien chez vous
depuis septembre 2015 vous confirmez que
globalement il n'y a pas de problème je
pense qu'il n'y a pas que à bonal je lis
aussi je recherche dans la presse
nationale des endroits où il ya eu d
accueil de nos grands il ya d'autres
petits villages en france ça se passait
bien
savait il faut pour que ça se passe bien
il faut qu'il y ait un climat de
confiance qui s'établissent entre les
habitants les élus ça c'est primordial
mais également et tous les services type
le sens de l'état donc la préfecture la
sous préfecture les services de la
cohésion sociale le l'offre l'offre à
l'office public de du moins de vols dues
au fisc français d'accueil des des
réfugiés et des apatrides
il faut bien sûr une structure d'accueil
qui tienne la route c'est qu'on ne
s'improvise pas accueillant des migrants
il faut des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'humanité mais aussi qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement les règles pour que les
gens qui sont de passage dans un
monastère tel que celui de bonnel par
exemple il faut qu'il sache qu'au bout
d'un certain temps ces gens là on les
papiers pour voir partir ils ne sont que
en transition se jugent qu'une paire
supérieure de régularisation mais c'est
en aucun cas leur dire vous arrivez ici
vous allez vivre jusqu'à la fin de vos
jours aussi donc il faut vraiment que
tout cet accueil là qu'ils soient très
bien organisée et comment vous expliquer
ce décalage entre la crainte que peuvent
exprimer certains élus la population
aussi généralement et puis finalement
c'est bonne expérience que vous vous
faites d'autres villes vous les avez
vous les avez mentionné est ce que
finalement il ya une crainte qui est un
peu un peu exagéré au départ qu'il faut
savoir peut-être dépassé aussi c'est
peut-être ça aussi le rôle de l'état de
ne pas être forcé la main pour montrer
que ça va que ça peut bien se passait
généralement est allé au delà des
craintes qui peuvent être aussi naturel
et et compréhensive plutôt que de forcer
je pense que l'état doit assurer
l'avenir de ces lieux d'accueil je crois
que quand on ne sait quand on voit
arriver les personnes et que l'on ne
sait pas du tout quand même temps ils
vont rester comment ça va se passer qui
va les accueillir je pense que toutes
ces inquiétudes la doit être levé sur
toutes ces interrogations là doit être
levé sinon bien sûr l'inquiétude fin je
sais que le maire de merpins accueillis
au courant de l'été des gens dans un
gymnase d'ailleurs c'est l'équipe
encadrante désoriente de venelles qui
sont qui était présent pour l'époque ça
s'est très bien passé je lui ai appris
même le maire lui même j'ai vu des îles
a dit dans la presse comme quoi ça
s'était bien passé mais lui refaire la
même chose aujourd'hui en lui disant
sans me prévenir lui réquisitionnés en
local pour dire un nouveau il en arrive
ça fait pas très sérieux quoique pour
que tout se passe bien le plus important
c'est en fait ça en amont que tout soit
calé qui les services suffisants que que
les mères soit au courant c'est comme ça
la meilleure recette qu'ont à dire ce
serait la même recette mais c'est vrai
que si nous on nous avait demandé à la
mairie de bonnel au mois d août 2015 si
on était prêt à accueillir soixante dix
huit migrants ou insère des oranges je
ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons accueilli
cette nouvelle là avec enthousiasme je
pense qu'il faut aussi un petit peu
d'imprévu et effectivement il faut
pousser un petit peu mais pas pousser
complètement et là je reprendrai par
rapport à ce que vous avez montré en
début ces demeures de bord pas je le
comprends très bien se sont ressentis il
a bien dit que maintenant ça va mieux
parce qu'il a réussi à déplacer des gens
sur sur notre lieu très franchement les
îles à vie s'ils avaient été associés au
moins pour le choix du lieu peut-être
que je ne serais pas arrivée là haut dès
le début quoi je pense qu'il faut quand
même une certaine approche il faut aussi
que l'état ait confiance au maire je
reviens toujours à ce cette confiance
une confiance réciproque très
franchement et qu'il doit exister à tous
les niveaux nous devons nous faire
l'interface toujours entre les gens qui
arrivent et deux habitants les habitants
ont confiance en nous nous avons
confiance en eux il faut qu'il y ait une
confiance franche esprits avec votre
expérience à vous de maire de beaune
elle est ce que vous faites l'interface
vous avec certains de vos collègues
voisins en disant mais t'inquiète pas ça
peut ça peut aussi ça peut souvent se
passait très bien
fait l'interface de temps en temps mais
je ne leur dis pas t'inquiète pas je
leur explique ce qui s'est passé et je
le redis à eux jugés et faites ce que
vous voulez très franchement je ne je ne
me permettrai jamais de ce d'aller jouer
au maire zorro qui va dans une commune
ce n'est pas du tout mon style par
contre s'ils veulent profiter d'une
expérience vécue oui je le ferais un
grand plaisir je lui fais de certaines
communes qui m'ont appelé qui m'ont
demandé depuis je n'ai pas de nouvelles
je sais qu'il ya des migrants qui sont
arrivés chez eux mais tant mieux et si
ça se passe mieux j'en suis et j'en suis
ravi et quoi on passe désormais au reste
de l'actualité
[Musique]
dont l'actualité cette semaine la région
ile de france présenté le bilan de son
bouclier sécurité lancée en janvier
celui ci prévoit notamment le
développement des équipements de
vidéosurveillance ou encore le
renforcement des moyens matériels pour
les policiers les précisions
un budget multiplié par trois une
priorité assumer la sécurité reste un
enjeu majeur pour valérie pécresse la
présidente les républicains de la région
ile-de-france est de 18 millions d'euros
en 2016 pour soutenir notamment les
communes dans leurs différentes
démarches à méré par exemple dans les
yvelines la ville a perçu près de 100000
euros pour l'installation de cinq
nouvelles caméras s'agit pas que la
région près de la main sur la sécurité
il s'agit que nous ayons toutes les
communes donc quand un maire souhaite
installer des vidéoprotection rénové de
la vidéoprotection est équipé sa police
municipale est bien la région peut
l'aider financièrement et c'est ce qu'on
a fait cette année en doublant le ce
budget qui était avant à la région
la sécurisation des îles de loisirs
comme celle de saint quentin en yvelines
ou encore des lycées sont également des
priorités de la région depuis la mise en
place du bouclier sécurité en janvier
les transports en commun de leur côté
seront tous dotés de la vidéoprotection
d'ici 2021
la vidéoprotection ça ne marche que si
y'a pas d'angle mort que si tout le
réseau est entièrement couvert sinon
évidemment les actes de délinquance se
produisent là où il n'y a pas de caméra
donc nous avons décidé de faire un plan
100% vidéoprotection dans les trains
avec le renouvellement du matériel
roulant nous y arriverons avant la fin
de la mandature et nous équiperons 70
gares routières dès cette année en lien
avec le ministère de l'intérieur et en
réponse à l'actualité du moment la
région accélère aussi son soutien aux
forces de l'ordre plus de 5 et millions
d'euros sont ainsi consacrés à la
rénovation des commissariats et des
casernes francilienne dans les yvelines
les casernes des quevilly et saint
germain en laye ont reçu des
financements régionaux
et guy poupart on l'a vu dans ce
reportage la région a fait de la
sécurité l'une de ses priorités et
souhaite aider les communes qui ont
besoin des deux financiers pour équiper
les agents installer des caméras de
vidéosurveillance est ce qu'une petite
ville comme vous une ville rurale 2000
habitants a aujourd'hui besoin de
soutien pour financer des équipements
pour assurer sa sécurité
si nous étions obligés de faire des
vidéos surveillances j'aurai besoin d'un
soutien financier évidemment mais par
contre si on me demandait ce que vous
souhaitez la vidéosurveillance très
sincèrement aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas et si pour certain qu'il faudrait le
rapprochement entre l'arrivée de
migrants sur le village et nous avons
anticipé ma prochaine question certains
c'est là c'est pas un argument parfois
quand les gens ne veulent pas des
migrants s'est il dit voilà il peut y
avoir des problèmes de sécurité ça peut
engendrer des problèmes de sécurité à
tort ou à raison qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez pour moi l'arrivée des migrants
ça fait monter sur une population et
bonnel de 70 personnes dont 90
aujourd'hui mais ce ne sont pas des gens
qui sont plus dangereux que les autres
très sincèrement je ne me vois mal leur
dire bienvenue mais pour vous surveiller
on va mettre des caméras pour voir ce
que vous faites quoi très franchement
non je le ressens pas je le ressens pas
et mon conseil municipal ne le ressens
pas et n'en ressent pas la nécessité et
je n'ai aucune aucun habitant qui est
venu nous dire vous savez maintenant
qu'il ya des migrants sur la commune il
nous faudrait de la vidéosurveillance
les jeunes migrants qui sont en ce
moment au monastère des auront tous les
jours vont jouer au foot sur le terrain
de foot de bonnel et deux passes il
passe devant l'école à dix mètres devant
l'école quand à 16h30 les enfants sont
de l'école maternelle école élémentaire
et bien devant ils trouvent des y croise
des tibétains y croise des syriens des
miracles et un des afghans jeu
franchement je n'ai pas senti la moindre
crainte moindre inquiétude les enfants
jouent les parents ils sont copains
comme d'habitude quoi ça nous n'avons
pas changé nos habitudes et vous ne
disiez pendant le reportage il faut pas
oublier que ce sont des êtres humains ce
sont des êtres humains sont des jeunes
des hommes des femmes parfois des
enfants nous avons eu trois enfants
abandonnés mais sans vraiment ils sont
je dirais ils sont comme des bouts des
lois qu'on n'a pas de bonnes elles en un
seul et unique bonnel qui contient
aujourd'hui un centre où il ya 90
personnes que nous n'avions pas
l'habitude de voir mais ça soit la
couenne en jeu sur la vie de production
si on nous oblige à en installer bien
sûr le fera parce que le maire ne vois
pas trop pourquoi je me reposerai si ça
peut s'allier à une sécurité nationale
mais c'est dans ce cas là bien sûr je
remercie valérie pécresse
nous offrent les pas de la possibilité
de financer une partie mais nous ne
sommes pas demandeurs aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les débats actuellement pour
revenir à cet aspect sécuritaire les
programmes politiques les attentats la
colère des policiers et des forces de
l'ordre en ce moment qu'ils expriment
depuis plusieurs jours on a l'impression
que que la question sécuritaire s'est
dégradée la sécurité s'est dégradée en
france vous en qualité de maire d'une
petite commune
quel regard vous portez sur cette
analyse est ce que c'est exagéré ou est
ce que vous constatez vous aussi qu' on
est moins en sécurité aujourd'hui en
france que qu'avant on ne ressent pas
trop dans nos villages si ce n'est quand
même des menus larcins c'est à dire des
vols de voitures et des voir dans les
maisons si on le ressent un peu plus
maintenant que nous ne ressentions ya
quelques années ça c'est flagrant et
d'ailleurs je crois je prends revenir à
la vidéoprotection je crois que dans le
secteur il souhaiterait installer délais
de production plus pour voir les gens
rentrer et sortir du village pour
essayer de piste et ceux qui ont fait
des dons qui on voulait plutôt que de
pistes est un endroit particulier pour
le pour le surveiller quoi oui mais on a
on ressent effectivement que jamais mais
pas autant que paris polar départ en
espagne heureusement croisement
heureusement je souhaite vraiment que je
n'ai pas que ce que ça n'arrive pas dans
nos villages dont l'actualité cette
semaine aussi le projet du grand paris
en vidéo c'est 16 prod agence de
communication audiovisuelle a situé à
plaisir rafle toutes les distinctions
avec son film sur le grand paris ce
projet et nivet est née suite à une
commande est fait aujourd'hui le tour
des festivals avec camille lambert a
rencontré son producteur reportage
je rêve d'une ville qui raconte notre
histoire
et qu'ils imaginent l'avenir
[Musique]
le grand paris se dévoile sous la forme
d'un film quatre minutes pour présenter
ce projet qui ont multiplié les
distinctions le film a reçu en octobre
trois prix lors des festivals cannes
corporate et médine corporate de
deauville derrière ce succès david
martin et sa société de production
originaire de plaisir on espère et on
espérait vraiment avoir un peu de succès
m un retour très positif sur ce film
parce qu'on s'est vraiment investi
c'est un vrai défi on a tourné avec des
caméras
vraiment dernière génération pour faire
des traits des images très ralenti comme
on peut voir le saut la personne qui
saute
depuis la gare du champ de mars au
château de versailles vingt jours de
tournage dans toute l'ile-de-france ont
été nécessaires commandé par la société
du grand paris le clip a été diffusé en
juillet dans les ambassades françaises
derrière cette première diffusion ils
sont été en fait
sensibiliser les investisseurs
internationaux pour les pousser à
participer à investir dans le grand
paris et dans les quartiers de demain
qui nous ont tout de suite fait
confiance en fait pour qu'on leur
propose plutôt un film original qui
sortent des films institutionnels qu'on
peut voir en général et qui privilégie
justement l'humain l'émotion
pour
pour commencer à sensibiliser les gens
en fait c'est sprott fête cette année
ses 10 ans c'est la première fois qu'un
de ses films est récompensé l'oeuvre
continue de faire le tour des festivals
prochaine étape tokyo verdict le 25
novembre
le projet du grand paris quel regard
vous portez vous dessus vous êtes une
commune qui est concerné forcément par
ce sujet plus de transport plus de
logements c'est une aubaine pour une
petite commune comme vous alors ça ça
vous fait craindre le pire notamment
d'être peut-être miz miz des mises de
côté encore plus puisque c'est le
sentiment qu'on a parfois en grande
couronne quand on est une petite ville
alors nous sommes une petite commune
c'est vrai de 2000 habitants comme je me
fais plaisir à dire c'est pas un endroit
où on habite mais bien ont envie qu'on a
il est vrai petit village et sept
villages nous souffrons tout pour le
conserver pour la conserver mais notre
adhésion au parc naturel régional la
haute vallée de chevreuse je pense me me
confortent dans cette position là je
pense que le parc soit en juin gardera
cette identité naturelle identité rurale
et après le grand paris c'est vrai que
ça nous semble très importante c'est
sûrement utile je ne fais pas la
politique nationale mais je vois aurait
la ligne 18 qui va pas passé très loin
de chez vous pas à pas tout à fait à
côté mais dans le coin notamment à saint
quentin oui mais voilà oui tout à fait
mais bon on a déjà
or dès qu'arrive à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse s'il a levé sur
le chemin était dans un état excellent
c'est parfait à titre personnel je vais
de temps en vrai le jeu des transports
en commun actuel que de valeur alors
après c'est vrai comment iront nous sur
ce grand paris c'est vrai que c'est une
question que nous nous posons puisque
bon nombre de mes habitants travaillent
sur la plus petite couronne ne sert que
plus proche de paris et donc sont plutôt
que d'utiliser leur voiture si vous
pouvez utiliser les transports en commun
j'en serais ravi et ne soient recalés
pouvoir aller à certaines choses
attraper les rer c soit une excellente
chose et puis et puis on a une ligne de
bus cela qui fait deux kills prendre
l'autoroute jusqu'à ne sait pas d eau
qui passe à proximité a l'envié nous
souhaitons aussi avoir un rabattement
sur ces endroits là le grand paris c'est
bien mais c'est vrai que nous
souhaiterions vraiment ne pas être
oubliés parce que nous ne serons pas
dans l'emprise exacte du grand paris
doucement dans la périphérie du grand
paris nous souhaitons vraiment pouvoir y
accéder au grand paris plus facilement
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est pas
simple on passe à un sujet un peu plus
léger maintenant puisque cette semaine a
été marqué vous le savez par la
toussaint et la fête d'halloween la
rédaction de téléphiles vous a proposé
toute cette semaine une série de
reportages sur les légendes yvelinoise
retour social du cocher sans tête au
château de rambouillet une légende à
donner la chair de poule qui date du
xviiie siècle reportage de nicolas
landry mélanie poké et sera montage de
romain respini
les rambolitains entendait encore
aujourd'hui le bruit des roues d'un
carrosse autour du château dans les
années 1770 un riche propriétaire de
saint léger en yvelines décide d'emmener
sa compagne au château de rambouillet
pour une balade en carrosse dans le parc
à mi-chemin dans un endroit reculé du
parc le carrosse s'arrête et donc le
propriétaire décide d'aller voir ce qui
se passe et là il découvre son cocher
décapité qui tient encore les rênes donc
deux peurs il emmène sa belle et
s'enfuit l'histoire vieille de trois
siècles se transmet entre les employés
du château c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
travaille qui nous en a parlé donc ça
remonte à traquer le années quand même
puisque parfois il essayé de savoir en
allant se balader dans le parc quand il
avait pas beaucoup de monde mais c'est
d'entendre ce bruit mais je pense qu'il
faut attendre la nuit tombée quand même
un point pour l'entendre
le fantôme du cocher hante le domaine
royal mais pas seulement louis xiv sur
l'eau dce ou plusieurs présidents de la
troisième république y ont séjourné et
leur esprit rendrait dans les lieux avec
tous les personnages qui sont passés
dans ce château on peut peut-être enfin
moi j'y crois a d'autres qui sont
cartésien n'y croiront pas du tout mais
moi je me dis que pourquoi pas justement
avoir des âmes des personnes qui sont
passés par ici qu'ils restent dans les
murs une histoire peu connue des
visiteurs mais le message envoyé par le
château est clair les curieux sont les
bienvenus à rambouillet la présence des
fantômes n'est pas tabou
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci guy
poupart de nous avoir accompagnés
pendant toute cette émission cette demi
heure je rappelle que vous êtes le maire
sans étiquette de bonnel et vous y tenez
sans étiquette merci beaucoup pensaient
alors pu porter mon témoignage personnel
merci à vous aussi de nous avoir suivis
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]